the fact is is that the economy after it
hits trough shortly after Obama became
president it started picking up slowly
but we had a massive recovery period
which which followed into Trump but it
doesn't seem that material conditions
necessarily are what are really
dictating the kind of vibe of the
country or the vibe of particular
Generations
absolutely so I mean this this is one of
the questions
that I spent a lot of time on in the
book I spent a lot of time thinking
about because it's a real mystery
the economy started to do a lot better
after especially after about 2011.
um it was a turning point and just it
just roared back you know the stock
market came back unemployment went very
very low if you look at unemployment say
right before covid it's extremely low
things are going very very well median
incomes were going up
um yet that didn't really reflect the
mood in the country now some of that as
you mentioned politics is because of
trump and that had some you know
I think most people would agree a fairly
negative impact on the national
conversation and the and uh how
different but it's it's also kind of the
fact that he was possible you know
reflected massive you know well hey like
that's what yeah you know absolutely and
so I you know I think and I think you
have to you have to look at that closely
and um
there were a few things that I found in
doing the analyzes for the book that I
think it go a long way toward explaining
the rise of of trump and populism in in
general
um so one example
is it used to be that and you looked at
say depression and happiness and if you
looked at it by social class education
income
um occupational Prestige things like
this
for the silent generation for example
there really wasn't a whole lot of
difference
for happiness and mental health
depending on social class and then that
started to change so I agree I have a
lot of grass in the book
um
and those lines diverge they diverge
starting with the Boomers and then go
from there where in more recent years
you end up with a very big gap for
happiness and depression by educational
level and income
so
people with a college education for
example
happiness has stayed fairly stable
levels of depression fairly stable among
older people anyway
and then
lower income
those who don't have a college education
big increases so this these diverging
lines it really suggests that for this
segment of the country
um working class let's call them
huge amounts of dissatisfaction
and that explains Trump in a lot of ways
um can I just uh uh Linger on this a
little bit you also point out something
that's really fascinating that you know
and and well as as to backfill a little
bit and you know I'm genuinely obsessed
with these kind of generational issues
because my parents were born in 1923 and
1927 so technically in your schema one
is greatest generation one is uh silent
generation but they are so in my mind so
clearly part of the same generation
um in the experiences that have the
attitudes that they formed and and you
know so many different things go into
that but one of the things that is
fascinating to me is that you show that
it's really the baby boom generation
when depression kicks in or when when
this kind of existential I I prefer to
think of it as existential lengths
that's when it kicked in my parents were
not happy people they were not wealthy
people they were not educated people
um but they kind of expected life to
suck they would talk often about how you
know so they were born to Immigrant
families uh in the 20s then the
depressed you know and they were dealing
with a bunch of then then the
Depression hit then World War II my
father served in World War II at the end
of the war after you know even after uh
VJ Day he and my mother said well we
just we were glad the war was over but
we just expected Our Lives to be a flat
line of kind of pretty shitty a little
bit better than subsistence level
existence but not much because their
entire life had been kind of flat
economically and then something changed
you know do you think that do you think
that this is actually a change in like
you know the prevalence of of this sort
of existential angst the prevalence of
depression things like that or just a
change in our our cultural language
around it
yeah we know for sure that that isn't it
because you also see the same Trends in
things like suicide
and self-harm and so on uh and the the
trends for of those objectively measured
behaviors are almost exactly the same as
the trends and say reports of symptoms
um and that's what that's when we're
talking about these things it's not
based on diagnoses it's not based on
people being more willing to talk about
things publicly it's Anonymous surveys
about symptoms which one most people
don't even know are depression and these
objectively measured behaviors but the
but the rise in the I mean the Boomers
among all the other firsts that they
either were or they claim to is they're
the first massively unhappy cohort right
yes and then Gen X also not great a
little bit better the X was kind of flat
you know I mean so early on in their
teen years the suicide rate was way up
for for Gen X but there may be other
reasons for that
um because that's that the that's one of
the few places where the suicide
statistics kind of diverged from some of
the depression ones but yeah I mean it's
the if you look across all the
generations it's kind of a complex
picture for the trends in mental health
um
the silent generation actually a better
mental health than the greatest
Generation before them maybe because
they they didn't fight in World War II
didn't and didn't have the huge impact
of the Great Depression uh and then for
Boomers it gets significantly worse yeah
much more depression than and on
unhappiness and suicide rates go up uh
Gen X kind of stays the course right I
mean a couple of couple surveys even
looks a little better at least as adults
um when they were younger not so much a
lot of unhappiness
um and then Millennials very mixed
picture for Millennials for mental
health
um as young people a lot of things
improved actually happiness actually
went up among teens
um depression went down by a little bit
but as adults not so much depression
starts to increase again and then for
Gen Z that is a place where we have
extremely consistent data across pretty
much every survey and indicator that
mental health got a lot worse for teens
and young adults starting around 2012.
yeah so yeah I'm I'm skeptical though
like what if what if familiar
Generations I mean they were dealing
with at the same level of mental health
issues they just dealt with it in
different ways because you know there is
there's some evidence that things like
you know attention to suicides can
increase people's you know propensity to
think that is the solution whereas you
know maybe you're depressed you're
depressed like 30 something or 40
something in the 1930s and you just like
quietly drink yourself to death instead
of necessarily you know taking your own
life like I I don't know I I don't think
it's necessarily different suicide rates
I think if that were true it would be a
linear Trend and it's not a linear Trend
it goes in and out so the silent
generation actually a better mental
health than the greatest before them
from the data but it but it is I
wouldn't expect that curve if it was
just oh the older Generations are more
stoic or something but it was a curve
there is something odd going on where as
America kind of like kicks free of
material uh poverty or Misery after
World War II where everybody you know
and there's there's disparities in
wealth but like the Baseline most people
have housing you know clothing shelter
some level or access to education and
dissatisfaction with life goes up I mean
it almost to me it seems that it's you
know we have succeeded you know far
beyond Abraham Maslow's greatest uh
dreams of bumping up the hierarchy of
needs and it's like oh yeah the one
thing that you need to do then is also
invent meaning and significance on a
daily basis I mean we're all
existentialism we're living in a world
where all of those institutions that
kind of channeled our energy or
restricted our choices have started to
fade because Gene one of one of the I
think great themes in your book is about
and this you know goes back to at least
the beginning of the Industrial
Revolution or of the modern period
modernity
um that people are more individualistic
uh people have more choices and you know
I hate to you know quote Spider-Man but
you know with great uh with great power
comes great responsibility right like
we're all left
having to make sense of our lives at a
time when all the institutions that
either did that for us or told us shut
up don't do don't think just follow
tradition they're all kind of missing
right yeah I mean this this began with
the Boomers and this is the Dilemma
that's still with us today that was an
excerpt from my interview with Liz Nolan
Brown of reason and Gene twangy author
most recently of generations if you want
to see another excerpt go here and if
you want to see the full conversation go
here and make sure to come back every
Thursday at 1 pm eastern time when
reason is talking to people with
something very interesting to say that
you definitely want to hear